you know full on full  I like this yeah the move just says okay  you're you're going to do some  absolutely [ __ ] things yeah let me  let me show you  you know because you know this this  actually is now why is failing to  equalize against Knight c3h5 which I  think is  uh very good banter  not anymore  I mean they are enjoying this which I  think is the sort of the proper spirit  yeah for sure although I don't I don't  know if Magnus can out [ __ ] do above  I feel like duboff has a wider  repertoire of [ __ ] it's possible  yeah but I mean Knight c3h5 is hard to  beat and I mean 193 was I think  establishing kind of the ground rules as  early as possible because uh it was very  much kind of a statement of intent  saying uh I am not going to let you be  the person who makes the worst moves in  the position for very long